An expat is Andrew take.
After eight years as a barrister followed by nineteen years as a member of the New South Wales they just dip assembly
eleven of them on the front bench.
Andrew tink stepped back from active politics in two thousand and seven to concentrate on writing Andrew's first book.
William Charles Wentworth one day and I in IP I should say CIA away from the award for literature in two thousand
and in the second law at Sydney was published in two thousand and eleven
and he stood a disaster Cambra in two thousand and thirteen.
Andrew slightest book a strike nineteen one to two thousand and one
and narrative history was released in November two thousand and fourteen.
Andrew is an edge on Professor University's Law School and a trustee of Sydney living museums in two thousand
and thirteen.
He was awarded an honorary doctorate of letters University and on the strategy I three thousand and fourteen.
He was made a member of the Order of Australia in January two thousand and fifteen.
Andrew commenced a three year appointment as president of the lottery Council the south while he's going to be talking
to us the soft unknown on the subject of Magna Carta is round about relevance to early New South Wales
and I'd ask you to welcome him. Thank. Thanks very much diverted. Look there's one thing too.
I need to explain and that is so I've had radiation. That's right.
Cancer and I get a very dry mouth so to drink from this bottle with on. But it can Times water not alcohol but.
According to the Philosopher
and jurist Jeremy Bentham the detention of what he called explored convicts in the colonies was a breach of Magna Carta
which he said applauded New South while. As well as in England.
Such was Bentham's prominence in the light of centuries that I expected to find numerous references to Magna Carta.
In the early colonial records of New South whiles especially the early court cases.
Diving clock mention the waiting twenty seven
when I saw understood him it was the presiding magistrate who literally saying Magna Carta surprises not the litigant.
But apart from this. I couldn't find any mention of Magna Carta.
You know either the cushier reports
or Dowling Select Case is which between them cover many of the court reports between seventeen and I in forty three.
Given these striving in Senate swep saw it climbs that Magna Carta reason much quoted by strident
when they're representing themselves in court cases.
I wondered why their ancestors didn't appear to do a lot more lies.
Perhaps I was smart a litigant seen person is more modern litigants that die the clock referred to a little bit earlier
that fellow coins land too said you had to coin something.
At one level it can be argued that Bentham was wrong
and that there was nothing in our the transportation act of seventy ninety four the active part of the status in New
South Wales which prevented a convict term expired from returning to England.
Other than the extreme distance and great expense involved.
But that does not necessarily explain in the absence of other references to the great shot at you know in New South
whiles what might help to do is the fact that from as early as July seventh I.
The common Lords applaud in the convict colony head in a kiddie respect. Let the haid of that applaud in England.
So we've bought clothes on of Magna Carta as agreed to Boy King John in twelve fifteen.
There was an acknowledgment of the primacy of the common law
and this was recognised as one of the minor ongoing legacies of the settlement.
Between the king and his barons at Runnymede.
Then in some wise from its earliest dies earliest colonial dies New South Wiles was ahead of England
when a kind of fundamental rights.
Had been this piece when an examination of rather early colonial records such as newspaper reports
and dispatches between New South Wales officials and the British government.
Reveals that there's nothing about Magna Carta or until twenty seven
and then on the a few mentions that played a route by adding thirty one in my view the answer.
Laws principally with Lord Sydney. Who was probably responsible for sending the First Fleet to botany by.
And with the convict colonies first and fifth governess to Philip unlocked and McQuarrie large city in Lawton man.
Over the last light hundred years the importance of Magna Carta as waxed
and wind the summit continues to be the defining recognition of ancient liberties reaching back at least the time of it
with the confessed up for others a great shot it was never more than a tenuous place treaty between King John
and his rebellious barons.
But even this more restricted view employed a direct challenge to King John's climb to rule by divine right.
And it was the Stuart Kings climbs to rule by the will of God alone in the seventeenth century which guy Magna Carta
renewed relevance.
When Charles the Second asserted in the sixth nineties that God had put him on the throne
and I only God could remove him.
It was Lord Sydney's great right Uncle Algernon Sidney with an eye who counted in discourses concerning government the
quote the peril regionally in the people of England delegated into the power of men and we might therefore China.
Tycho why kings in discourses Sydney laws specifically on Magna contact to support his proposition that to depend on
the will of a man is sly free. Sidney said. This was without doubt to establish this among us by Magna Carta.
Similarly to Granny's assertion that laws are not my boy kings because nice ones will be governed by a rule
and not really.
Sidney wrote The Great shot of that recapitulates
and acknowledges there I shall inherit liberties a blog is the king to swear that he will not have the sill to lie in
order not justice to any man according to the laws of the land.
For writing discourses and their boy daring to challenge King Charles a second's climb to rule by divine rule at right.
Sydney was tried for treason and found guilty and on the seventh of December sixth. He was beheaded.
There are often a lot of heroes of those who believe that the will of more not should be subject to the will of
parliament. Among them. Tommy Townsend.
A drop of the blood of Algernon Sidney vines towns in proudly told the House of Commons ninety years after his future.
Execution.
After suffering setbacks during these early career as a government hack always one of those once upon a time on towns
and began to support radical causes among them that of John Wilkes who had been repeatedly expelled from power meant
for defining King George the third to be repeatedly reelected boys constituents.
To perfect the plan of securing and guiding the liberties of the freest nice in the world against the future attacks
and wicked ministers were clime built on the firm Bice's of Magna Carta. Backing Wilkes to the hilt.
Tommy towns
and addressed the commons the members of this house must not ask whether the man whom the electors have chosen he's fit
company for them. Towns and say did he acquires an indisputable top to admission by that election and that election.
Is the author of the American Declaration of Independence to. Thomas Jefferson Leiter acknowledged.
Algernon Sydney a billion one of these inspirations.
In discourses Sydney it is that nothing can be more evident than that of many man it will mirroring this in his
declaration. Jefferson famously proclaimed We hold these truths to be self-evident that all men are created equal.
Alsono in Sydney is I very very bright political philosopher indeed not understood these dice because it was impossible
to really which is to cite was a great think about a bad writer. If you want to be remembered.
Well during the American Revolutionary War true to Algernon Sidney's principles bring among just a handful of members
of the House of Commons who strongly backed the revolt an American colonists as George the third like to call them all
wrong. McLean the new British government which emerged on to the war.
Tommy Townsend because I'm home secretary responsible for negotiating a peace treaty with the Americans.
To provide for American loyalists the king offered him a peerage. And that why Tommy towns in Sydney.
Then off the United States refused to accept any more British convicts it fell to Lloyd Sydney to find an alternative.
Refusing to adopt Jeremy Bentham to proposal to build a jaunt penitentiary
or pan up the can because it allowed a single watchman to observe all the inmates with at the end might spring I will
tell whether that watched. Sydney settled on a resumption of transportation this time to botany by.
The stewards of the transportation act of seventy ninety four which Lord Sydney to help to sponsor the British
Parliament convict I was see is quite could inflict such moderate punishment as might be inflicted on persons committed
to a house of correction.
So the convicts had substantial rights under British law just as their rivals say he's had substantial responsibilities
and this is now been generally accepted by a story and generous provision was might for the.
Governor Philip kept and what contains sport it was left to acting.
Tallie from judgment without the benefit of a council or other legal arrangements more in the spirit of Magna Carta.
He had he had been a great Philip to the constant sort of the legal arrangements more in the spirit of Magna Carta had
been agreed to by Sydney and Philip to the consternation of the First Lord of the Admiralty.
Among these was in the instruction of the convicts would be subject to the ordinary criminal law
and not to the hotshoe middle military law which applied to the Marines
and pursuant to let US patent law at Sydney established a court of civil jurisdiction which could hear an action upon
complaint to be my duty in writing to the court
or any personal persons against any other personal persons residing within the said place of any cause he's a story
that will strike what these millions implying that. As the first Floyd was ready.
Handed I would do the master of the transport by they July. John Simpson.
One of them six Susanna Holmes was accompanied by her infant son who the master of the transport refused to allow on
board.
A Pole that mother
and child would be separated because the child of course hadn't been convicted of an offense in the didn't have any
legal Bice's to.
Simpson took the infant and rode up to London where he had to remonstrate with somebody and I'm office.
Upon arrival Simpson bumped into the Home Office was very small just four rooms on the whole and only.
The Home Office including the secretary of state and the.
I ran the British Empire the most the internal government right Britain.
I got into when you on the wire hand there most of the night and people running when you.
Something's not quite right size Simpson bumped into loads of it was quickly convinced the saw on the pipe was that
would allow the infant to accompany its mother and almost as an afterthought he saw
and pipe was allowing the by the father a convict by the name of Henry Cavill to go to the press got hold of his story
and Keibler homes in the BY be quickly become celebrities sign much of the public dynamited to a trust fund to help
them on a wider botany by.
In their wisdom the trustees purchase clothes and books which were placed in a Haitian sack
and loaded on to the transport Alexandra on another vessel. When Kibo went to collect the sack after robbing of Sydney.
He was told by the Alexander's master Duncan Sinclair that the clothes that gone missing
and I knew the books could be found.
Meanwhile a court of civil jurisdiction a billion established and the Thai king advice for damages
and following a three day hearing in early July seventy ninety I presided over by the judge advocate diving colons Kibo
was awarded fifteen pounds in damages. So it was that in Cairo versus the first civil suit brought in a stride.
A convict successfully sued the monster of a first fleet transport for lost luggage.
You wouldn't do as well as that to die if you took on courts as a convict on the sentence Khyber would have been
and I will bring these climb for damages in England.
But in the convict colony different rules were applied
and in this why the common law which laws at the heart of Magna Carta.
Was more advanced in the big call and even it was in the ALL country. This on really critically important story.
Even in the face of general stop I shouldn't.
Govern I know so I should say that I do agree with John Hirst we've got to do something about the plot
and in Canberra it's not wrong.
Even in the face of general starvation Governor Philip exercised these enormous paths wisely
and this combined with these personal examples such as accepting the Russian help the Colin need to survive just as
important was the judicious use of the PAL would see the need given him to emancipate grant them land.
When Phillip the part of the seven day ninety two he handed I have a chance break in child of the COME ON DA this I
should in years of instability as light and I will govern a struggle to was by now politically entrenched coal
and its fellow travellers according to Jeffrey Watson down.
I see I see there's still a lot of
and well some allies played the simmering tensions finally climaxed on the twenty sixth of January
when the Johnson arrested governable on a ship government.
At a time when Britain was fighting for its lot of guys the French This decide the least was a risky strategy.
And so on. Surprisingly Johnson might no specific reference to Magna Carta The justify himself.
Even so he's dispatched of all account Caso right had a familiar ring to it.
Calvin a blog tried the high trust and confidence reposed in bars sovereign
and acted up on a pro determined plan to subvert the laws of his country to terrify
and influence the courts of justice
and the person who had the misfortune to be of noxious to him with a fortune to liberty
and the laws one act of oppression was succeeded.
Until a general sensation of alarm and terror profile throughout the settlements said Johnson to council right.
If King John had not so on the Magna Kadar in twelve fifteen the barons model of drawing up something similar.
Notwithstanding the.
It's between the early governors in the colonies political factions many inhabitants had been doing well in no small
part to the Polje to the policy Lord Sidney had sitting trying of emancipation and land grants
and thanks to the in-laws
and inside of the colonies fifth governor Laughlin McQuarrie recognized in a new policy which had on shore this is
wrought had now president in England.
So this is another example of the call of need to be calling looping ahead of them of a country
when it comes to fundamental rights on the thirtieth of by providing tain McCoury right to vote. I can't counsel right.
Upon myself to adopt a new law of conduct conceding that conceiving that emancipation
when you nodded with rectitude good conduct should lead a man back to the rank of society which he full fitted
and do a Y. In as far as the case will admit. All right.
Respect for my bad conduct these appears to me to be the greatest inducement that could be held out towards the
reformation of the manners of the inhabitants
and I think it is consistent with the gracious fiber of this class of people then explained that he allowed for X.
To dawn with him.
The principal surgeon Darcy Wentworth He's assistant William read from the prosperous farmer in the land Andrew Thomson
and the wealthy merchant Simeon low wall Wentworth and never in fact plain convicted of anything.
It was widely believed that he was a next Harlem and not without reason. On one side.
I have long conducted themselves with the greatest propriety McCoury said No I find them at all times ready to come
forward the most liberal man it was the systems of government toward this small quarry
and bars to be to point in Thompson as a magistrate in the whole.
And he would soon appoint Wentworth as magistrate seen Sydney. Had Jeremy Bentham span up the can be built.
It's difficult to imagine that would ever of delivered fully reform convicts on the skyll now contemplated by
government quarry. Nor would. Going to lead to see it as magistrates in England. I'm sure I'm writing something.
In this why the administration of lore in the colony had that of England
but the prospect of being judged boy offended many of the cycle exclusive for a setlist.
I'm not sure that if I go hold up before a magistrate in Paramount of all I would be very happy if I knew the name of.
That I never catch their objections these are the exclusive for the settlers playing judge boy.
They never cast their objections in terms of Magna Carta thirty nine of the twelfth edition.
We would have allowed them to do you know for a man should be persuaded against says except by the lawful judgment of
these pieces. Nevertheless the exclusives objected to London the batiks convict magistrates in there and why.
And as a result Commissioner John Big was appointed to inquire into the McCoury administration.
But the governor didn't help him. So when he to forward the commission.
And appointed another ex-con big William Redfern to the bench.
It was Das he went with son William Charles Wentworth who made the first comprehensive piece for constitutional reform
of the convict colony. You know statistical a story political.
Description of the colony of New South whiles a book written and published in England
and I went with proposed the introduction of trial by jury a free press and elected legislature
and an independent supreme court but nowhere in this book of almost five hundred pages.
Is there a reference to Magna Carta rather resign putting more general terms it's a fundamental maxim of the British
constitution went with right that Texas should be levied on the subject without his consent expressed boys
Representatives even to this maxim the rod is in directly FROM clause twelve of the. Right. Shot of that's the one of.
Which But gains that society. What was in a military tax nice a good age. All right.
Shall be imposed on at Kingdom unless part Common Council of that kingdom.
Which is no taxation without representation and argument according to some following on from Commission a big.
Reports twenty two an independent Supreme Court was established limited Troll Boy jury was implemented
and appointed Legislative Council was established to.
Success a Thomas Brisbane also introduced what he called the experiment of the four letter to the freedom of the press
and dissipating these concessions in the second edition of his book went with the written in the mind.
It's probable that all these privileges which the author has contended for will be considered accepting perhaps full
trial by jury and the establishment of a house of assembly and if those privileges of withheld little longer.
It will anybody from the conviction of the colony hasn't yet arrived sufficient degree
but you're ready for the reception an exercise of them.
The granting of these further constitutional considerations was ultimately an issue for the British government
and pollen and having been taught a lesson by the revolt of the American colonists less than half a century earlier.
It was a matter of when not if jury and elected legislature would be introduced.
However while a man supposed legal for these Chinese assoon as possible.
Some exclusives for the vigorous real God the lying action now divided especially by the prospect of being judged by
juries of X. Convex and other complication was Gov Brisbane successor Ralph dolling a prickly military not net.
Broader than any criticism of his administration of the colonies now often pointed newspaper editorials.
Indeed it was the convict.
Conflict between dolling
and I was pushing for reform which triggered the only direct official reference socket fawned on Magna Carta up to
white in forty four. To petition the king in both houses of parliament full trial by jury and elected legislature.
A public meeting was held at Sydney's courthouse on the twenty sixth January twenty seven there were a large crowd was
addressed by William Charles Wentworth.
Lee's Constitutional Rights belong as much to the people as the crown belong to the king he said I was a birthright of
the people and nothing but the strongest necessity could justify withholding them an instant.
So the petition itself set out to show why there was not just this no such necessity withhold them any further.
In relation to jury trials the petitions were careful to point out that the competency for trial by jury has been
proved boy upwards of two years' experience in that mode of trial in the colonies courts of Quarter Sessions.
Therefore the inference was that to extend that to all jury trials carried very little risk it would be an impact
incremental chime.
It was in relation to the call for an elected legislature of the petition involved to grant China referring to the
colonies annual revenue of sixty thousand pounds the petition is quite decent Norma's some isn't here the two billion
levied on your Majesty's humble petition is both already of power.
And other was without their consent contra to Magna Carta. And that ended the dispatches back to.
England as a nexus to the governor as official dispatches to the.
Well by then colonial secretary and that's how it was in the official record.
While the editor of Sydney's monitor news Piper described as contrary to an expressed quote was in Magna Carta.
My view is that it is that based on a reference to close twelve which I mentioned earlier.
Whatever the case the petition then addressed itself to the practical matter of whether they are enough people in.
The call only qualified to stand for election.
Their idea of the magistrate magistracies the petition
and three times as many gentlemen who will be fitted by their will
and talents to act as members of a ledge to the assembly. Such occupants left Governor dolling unimpressed.
And he's covering dispatch which accompanied the petition of the Colonial Secretary Lord Bathurst presentation to the
king darling said it started of in infancy.
At present reigned in New South Wales unfit for those institutions which in England as a result of its advancement
and maturity.
Now then anticipating this went with a swing to what the copies of the petition would be taken to London by Gregory
Blaxland and they are presented to sympathise as seen by Palma. As the editor of the city morning.
I'm honored to put it. Lord Bathurst is not as cold he will towards a house of the same.
We're glad therefore that power in the discipline petitioned as well as the King Live.
This campaign for constitutional reform had some years left to run.
I could only find references to Magna Carta up to white
and forty three by which time trial by jury in a posh elected legislature in the New South whiles the first reference
was in a letter to the Sydney is it published in the thirteenth of August twenty nine the quoting the Latin version of
Magna Carta schools thirty nine. Twelve edition.
There are derived at the free born children of a man's man supposed to have the benefits of unlimited trial by jury.
And the second reference appeared in an article in the stride in the thirtieth of July thirty climbing that upon the
principle of Magna Carter a verdict of twelve is to be a verdict of law the piper criticized
and identified court judgment on the vices that a positive jury verdict for the defendant had been replaced by a
special verdict of the judge. This was in fact a reference to the. Of pine number two.
According to the official court report.
The attorney general had allowed the case to go to the jury
and I found a verdict for the defendant against the direction of the judges who ruled that upon the playthings the
crown was in top of the judgment the defendants barristers Wardell and Wentworth that's W.
So he went with admitted on appeal that in strictness of law the defendant is not my dad any total against the Crown
but instead that iniquity the verdict stood as the colonies to the finest barristers Richard
and William Charles Wentworth must have now in Iraq human would not succeed.
So perhaps it's no coincidence that the appeal to Magna Carta.
Appeared without attribution in a news pipe which Wardell and went with had founded back in twenty four.
All are specific to references to Magna Carta during the convict first dies a few
and far between the nine of the last man to be executed for invoking it has been celebrated.
Since the twenty second of January seventeenth ID night
when Governor Philip Sidney after the home secretary Lord Sidney half so well thought of you
when he'd been offered a peerage for his role in securing a peace treaty with the revolt of American colonists the home
secretary then still now as Tommy Townsend charged the nine Sidney. For the top will. Algernon Sidney.
Algernon Sidney with and on.
So why is there a difference in the spelling between Sydney's we now with the law and Sydney with the on.
In fact first proposed with a no i did George the third.
But then he discovered what he called the elder branches of the family might have a climb on it.
So a right to the king as fall lies the consideration of the toilets occupies my thoughts no farther than to avoid
taking. Anyone which might clash with the pretensions of any other family.
If your Majesty will allow me to Chinese the toilets of Sydney with a wife sitting with a wall of chisel Hirst neither
of which a climb boy anybody and to which on the law. I'd bar the Sydney's in the V.
Is more relatives will be satisfied in that all offend. Nobody else.
In this roundabout why then the I'm a very bright city celebrates Algernon Sidney the last man to be martyred for
invoking Magna Carta against an absolute as British King thank you thank you.